what's the one word you hope your loved
one uses to describe you when you are
not around I will go with compassionate
because honest is like you know that's
code word for for you know what I mean
you know what I mean
it's like someone with no filter
honest all of them
compassionate are all of them I'm gonna
forgem this and say all of them why not
come on we are actors
kind of loaded you're right like other
than compass compassion I feel like if
you're intelligent it's like you're
pretentious
I'm going compassionate as well yeah
loyal is good but just to be different
I'll pick creative and I realize I've
been forgetting to click the buttons
this whole time and we have to click
yeah I haven't been clicking